president Trump pretty busy these days
very busy you probably heard latest
today President Trump met with the
victims of Hurricane Florence yeah yeah
the victim said this is the worst thing
that's ever happened to us
then they talked about the hurricane
yesterday you honor if you saw this CNN
devoted an entire segment this is what
we've come to an entire segment on CNN
devoted to president Trump's penis
yeah the segment was short blunt and
ended earlier than expected that's right
ya know I'm very proud of myself and I
did go to college stormy Daniels and her
new memoir stormy Daniels implies that
in exchange for sex Donald Trump offered
to rig the apprentice so she could win
yeah even worse Trump made the same
offer to Gary Busey and he took it to
story and he still didn't win good today
of course is the Jewish holy day of Yom
Kippur yep this is the day my Jewish
writers are out and my Catholic writers
have to Google what is Yom Kippur we
don't know yesterday yeah I've been
following this but yesterday a
spokesperson for Sesame Street said that
Bert and Ernie do not I repeat do not
have sexual orientation
the spokesperson then added but Big Bird
is really into asian chicks
you
you